get on a plane for a nice sightseeing
tour of Alaska this Thanksgiving we're
serving up some delicious mudo that's
right folks another episode of Monarch
Legacy of Monsters has arrived with all
new questions and theories including who
is hiroshi's real father the attack on
Godzilla and the introduction of a new
Titan remember that this is not a recap
video but an in-depth guide on all the
theories thus far and as usual I've left
timestamps below so you can see all the
topics I'll be covering and be sure to
stick around till the end of the video
as we'll be doing some trailer sleuthing
to see what could be in store for future
episodes now be sure to like And
subscribe I'm planning on covering the
entire season one of the show's big
Mysteries centers around The
Disappearance of Hiroshi Randa who after
Godzilla's appearance on gday had him
sneaking off to Alaska on an unknown
Mission Hiroshi used to work for Monarch
likely helping them build their vast
satellite network but has since gone
Rogue his mission is so important that
he he leaves his two families behind
leaving them to believe he died in the
Alaskan Wilderness thankfully due to May
uploading hoshi's data tapes tapes
originally held by Bill Randa they have
retrieved coordinates to a place in
Alaska but when the gang arrives
locating hiroshi's plane and tent
Hiroshi is nowhere to be found either
he's ventured deeper into the Alaskan
Wilderness has found a monarch facility
like that in king of the monsters or was
picked up by a second party we do see
this phone which he could use to
communicate with the outside world the
fate of hiroshi's pilot is much more
Grim the gang notes that he wasn't
wearing his seat Bel when their plane
supposedly crashed which is odd since
you'd probably want that on if your
plane was going down it's doho however
who realizes this was no plane crash
finding out Hoshi and the pilot had
actually landed safely and tied their
plane to the ice something they wouldn't
have done if it had crashed the plane w
rather was attacked by what's known as a
frost bark a giant mudo Titan with
breath so cold it can completely freeze
its prey while approaching its location
the plane's Control Systems malfunction
so it can be assumed that some sort of
radiation or electromagnetism from these
mudos cause Electronics to malfunction
the same can be seen in 1954 and the
arrival of Godzilla at bikini ATL while
analyzing the data tapes which may
conveniently uploaded to her laptop a
series of geoc coordinates are recovered
all of them except for the one from
Alaska had a check mark beside it since
the Alaskan location pinpointed to a
mudo it can be surmised that these other
locations point to other Titans if they
have check marks beside them could it
mean that Monarch has captured or killed
them last episode we saw may go behind
Cano's back and secretly upload the rest
of his father's data tapes to her laptop
in this episode we'll see her talk to an
unknown person and throw her cell phone
shortly thereafter into the ocean
considering this episode is called
secrets and lies I can't help but think
May is hiding something if there's one
person who could betray our team my
money's on her it seems the only thing
she wants is to get her business and
life back another secret the show is
kept hidden is the real relationship
between Lee Shaw and Hoshi Randa all we
know up until this point is that bill
and KO had a son named Hoshi and Lee was
like an uncle to him but in this episode
Lee says it was more like a father in
episode 2 we find out that Lee and
Hiroshi had some sort of falling out and
haven't talked since I think that Koo
and Lee may have had an affair and
Hiroshi found out about it if you want
to go one step further you could even
guess that Lee is hiroshi's father
making him the grandfather of both Kate
and canaro after all why would Hiroshi
keep documents about the guy who slept
with his mom tucked away in a filing
cabinet if there wasn't something more
there in 1954 we get a flashback Fe
featuring this giant cast of What
appears to be a Godzilla footprint it's
an impression that was made from a muddy
field in Indonesia in previous episodes
we saw Koo in a photograph in this
actual print Bill Koo and Lee have
secured 150 lbs of uranium from the
United States Army in an attempt to lure
this monster but unbeknownst to them the
Army has supplied it to them in the form
of a bomb we know these Titans feed off
radiation so a pile of uranium attracts
Godzilla who emerges from the watery
depths only to be nuked to Kingdom come
now we never really get to see the
aftermath of this explosion but it's
implied that Godzilla was obliterated we
know however that Godzilla isn't dead he
returns to San Francisco roughly 60
years later if I were to Hazard a guess
he crept back into the ocean after the
bomb went off I mean you could also
theorize there are more than one
Godzilla but considering Godzilla feeds
off radiation I don't think this bomb
would kill him given only one scene this
episode is monarchs Tim who we last saw
in Hot Pursuit of Kate and canaro he's
been chastised by his boss Natalia
Verdugo who task him with going to Korea
and retrieving Shaw's files there's
definitely some sort of history between
Tim and Verdugo he doesn't trust her and
vice versa she knows that Tim withheld
information about Shaw's escapades in
Japan and asks why if he thought his
files were so important did he not go to
Dr sarawa Dr sarawa you might remember
from 2014's Godzilla and 2019s Godzilla
king of the monsters since this show is
set in 2015 Sarah zawa is still alive
not dying until he sacrifices himself to
save Godzilla in king of the monsters I
also thought it was a bit weird that
Verdugo and Duval speak French here as
to not keep Tim informed what they're
talking about even though it's Duval who
says she can't do her Mission without
Tim there's a slight chance she may be
keeping an eye on Tim for Verdugo now we
get head into our trailer sleuthing
section where we take a look at the
trailers to see where the story might be
headed keep in mind I won't be covering
every shot just the ones I think are
valuable for the story ahead here we
have Lee Shaw looking at that film reel
of what might be Philippines 1952 he's
been captured just take a look at how
his hands are tied also notice how KO
looks at him furthering my suspicions
that these two had some sort of Affair
later we'll see them dancing together
and having a great time further proof
something something more is going on
here I'm wondering if this shot here is
Le captured by Natalie Verdugo and
Monarch since the back of her head here
looks like verdugos Hiroshi Randa lives
unless of course this is a flashback
he's definitely not in Alaska and take
note of this weird sphere in the
background some sort of scientific
device another such device can be found
in the inside look trailer sometime in
the 1950s we'll see young Lee get into a
different sort of sphere which may be
him and This Crew attempting to make it
get down into the hollow Earth where the
Titans originated and which we saw in
Godzilla versus Kong in the second
trailer we'll see the same sphere all
rusted and old which could be somewhere
in Alaska considering the winter coats
our characters are wearing here we see
canaro has plotted out these points on a
paper which shine light onto this map
similar to the one found in his father's
office it leads to coordinates in
Algeria May did say that one of the
geolocations she found in hiroshi's
files was North Africa here we see Lee
in front of a computer that reads Prime
could it be trying to detonate some sort
of device or bomb we may not be done
with Alaska as we see a bunch of
helicopters flying around this glowing
hole in the ground the same glow looks
oddly familiar to the radiation Trail Le
saw in the Philippines in 1952 he's in a
helicopter so I imagine he and the
others make it out of Alaska by being
captured by Monarch we'll later see Tim
is caught up to Kate and canaro at some
sort of airport well it looks like the
game survives the initial attack by the
frost Fark but is later stocked by it at
night Lee and the others will see the
frost far either consuming this glowing
radiation or being consumed by It
Whatever It Is they seem to be shocked
finally we have Godzilla's reappearance
in the desert we'll see people like
Duval here and Monarch helicopters the
gang is eventually taken to Monarch
headquarters but it's uncertain what
kind of Alliance if any they have but
now I turn it over to you what do you
you think will happen next I want to
hear your thoughts and theories in the
comments below thanks for watching be
sure to like And subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram @ thinkstory YT until next
time remember Daddy loves you very
much